there's a funny little thing going on
which I want to tell you about and it
has nothing to do with Donald Trump's
diet it's that in American politics
there are lots of formalities that sort
of don't really matter so I'll give you
an example did the losing presidential
candidate concede because if they
conceded it's over but if they didn't
concede they could still challenge the
results oh wait a second no the
concession is merely symbolic it's a
formality it doesn't really make any
practical difference I could give you
many other of those examples we have
upcoming the yearly State of the Union
address and as I've mentioned before
when the President of the United States
goes to the House of Representatives to
give their State of the Union address
we've mentioned before that the Speaker
of the House invites the president to
come to the house chamber to brief the
House and Senate about the state of the
United States of America it's normally a
formality yes an invitation letter is
sent and then the president shows up as
expected but we're quickly learning it's
not just a formality because if the
speaker doesn't invite the President or
rescinds an invitation the president
can't just show up and give a speech
right now we find ourselves in a
situation where government is shut down
Nancy Pelosi is the new Speaker of the
House now that Democrats have been sworn
in and have taken control in that
chamber and she's uninvited Trump from
giving the State of the Union address
via a letter that she sent yesterday the
formal reason she cites in the letter
which were showing our television and
video audience the formal reason is that
we've got a government shutdown going on
there are security concerns for having
the president in the House chamber you
can sort of read between the lines if
you want and I think that that's exactly
as designed right now the state of the
union is scheduled for January 29 and
Nancy Pelosi is suggesting or deciding
that it will be postponed to another
quote suitable date or for Trump to just
send a letter to deliver the entire
speech in writing this is a nice little
strategic move because the State of the
Union speech would be used by Trump to
propagandize
about the border wall and about the
so-called immigration crisis and you
might say hold on but David every state
of the union is a political speech where
the president is going to evangelize for
what they want to see done yes that's
true but we know that in this particular
case Stephen Miller and other advisors
have been working on Trump's speech
there is every plan to have it be a cry
basically a build the wall rally of
sorts and Nancy Pelosi is saying the
government shutdown you're not going to
do it and this is not without precedent
this isn't something Nancy Pelosi came
up with herself out of thin air on a
whim the state of the union has never
been delivered during a government
shutdown previously it would frequently
be delivered in writing that's not
really unique novel or new in any way
but on paper the security explanation is
completely defensible even if we do read
through it as a political thing the
Department of Homeland Security
Secretary Kirsten Nielsen said that the
State of the Union address is a national
special security event and NSSE and that
NS SES require the full resources of the
federal government right now we're in a
partial government shutdown we don't
have the full resources of the federal
government Secret Service which
implements security for NS SES and DHS
haven't been funded for now something
like four weeks and what I really like
about this Pat is that it's hitting
Trump where it hurts not letting him
talk to cameras which he loves
not allowing him to go in there and have
everybody cheer for him which he loves
there are lots of Trumpets who just have
no idea what's going on and they say
well Trump's entitled to give the speech
and Nancy Pelosi can't do this no this
is by invitation Trump can submit his
speech and writing he can request a
later date but Nancy Pelosi is not
asking here Nancy Pelosi is telling and
that's it yeah the Constitution mandates
that the president keep Congress up to
date on what's going on in the country
from time to time it doesn't say that it
has to be every year and I think this is
definitely a politically savvy move on
the part of Nancy Pelosi because as you
pointed out there are times during the
speech where both chambers both parties
are
cheering the president and that's
definitely going to make him look good
which Democrats certainly don't want and
then of course corporate media's gonna
go on and on about how the president
gave such a great speech and that could
up his approval rating get people to
side with him on the government shutdown
it would not be good for the Democratic
Party well let's talk about the Pelosi
part because there are emails that I'm
starting to get and tweets that I'm
starting to see saying Pelosi's bungling
it she's going too hard against Trump
with the shutdown and the State of the
Union and all of the stuff for everybody
who thinks Nancy Pelosi is messing up
with how she's behaved since she became
Speaker of the House you were very very
wrong Nancy Pelosi's approval is going
up the more she opposes Trump
particularly on the shutdown and on
border wall funding the more her
approval goes up she's doing the right
thing here she's not letting the
petulant child Donald Trump get away
with his antics she I've never been a
massive Nancy Pelosi fan on policy I'm
to her left and feels she's too
conservative on many issues but she's
not caving and giving Republicans and
Trump what they want and people are
reacting to it positively so you can
argue you think that these are long-term
strategic mistakes or that they are sort
of debasing and corseting the politics
of the United States you could make all
those cases if you want although I would
respond and say the Donald Trump's been
doing the exact same thing but to argue
that at least in the short term these
are good decisions by Nancy Pelosi goes
directly counter to the approval numbers
that we're seeing by missing something
about it let me know the David Pakman
show is on instagram at david pakman
show make sure that you follow us there
for what do we have there behind the
scenes pictures polls I sometimes will
answer questions from viewers on the
Instagram account David Pakman show we
have pictures of Pat's Pat cave at the
studio which a lot of people like and it
also helps to insure Pat Safety he's not
just in a pitch-black room surrounded by
equipment lots of cool stuff on the
David Pakman show instagram at david
pakman show and while you're there
follow me i'm on instagram at day
dot Pakman one of today's sponsors is
privacy calm slash Pakman this is a free
service that I've actually been using
myself for a while now and I love it you
just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or bank account to privacy
calms mobile app or browser extension
for Firefox and Chrome and what that
does is allow you to instantly create
virtual credit cards that are linked to
your bank account so that you're not
actually putting your real debit card
number on the internet and you use these
virtual credit card numbers to buy
things online and with one click of a
button you have the ability to create
multiple virtual cards delete cards
freeze and unfreeze cards you can put a
limit on a card so a company won't be
able to charge you more than you
actually want them to and it protects
you from being hacked it protects you
from companies being hacked which we've
been talking about for a while on the
program and it's perfect for signing up
for free trial somewhere if you don't
want your real credit card number to be
exposed and on file and their app and
browser extension let you autofill the
virtual credit card number into the
credit card field when you're buying
things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5 towards your first purchase when
you sign up using that link below